[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sportwart bord
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers mein name ist andreas an er
ich bin selbst herr dass sportler und
wir wollen euch hier beim sport trat die
spannenden persönlichkeiten hinter den
vielen heeres sportlerinnen und
sportlern des österreichischen
bundesheers präsentieren heute zu gast
im sport sagt thomas frühwirth handbiker
und partner triathlet und alleskönner in
dem sinne ich freue mich sehr dass du
heute bei uns im studio ist herzlich
willkommen
hallo danke wieder einmal wie geht's dir
waren die letzten monate für dich ja
danke körperlich jetzt war ausgezeichnet
natürlich ist für alle da sehr
anspruchsvolle zeit und 2020 war
natürlich auch wettkampfjahr heißt im
prinzip zum streichen gewesen ist
ja es ist von der uci- eigentlich die
komplette weltcup geben und auch die wm
abgesagt worden
dadurch haben wir dann mehr auf meine
eigene leistungsentwicklung konzentriert
und mir auch wieder ein kleiner
abstecher in den triathlon weekend und
das auch sehr erfolgreich darauf kommen
wir auch gleich zurück du wirst
triathlet du bist handbiker du sitzt im
rollstuhl für die die sich jetzt nicht
sehen dass eine komplette
querschnittslähmung seit 2004 was es da
genau passiert also über ursprünglich
mal im motorsport aktiv wird auch bei
ktm entwicklungen oberösterreich tätig
sieben jahre
ja was um eine erste große sport liebe
war dann aber nicht bei einem entwürfe
oder motocross rennen sondern auf einer
urlaubsreise wir waren darüber norwegen
schweden finnland unterwegs und dann
wasserball harmlos eigentlich
kerzengerade autobahn zwischen warschau
und krakau und da war nur schlechte
spiele bzw einige schlechte spurrillen
dir einfach erwischt jetzt relativ
harmlos hingelegt aber mit dahin
geschlittert leicht geregnet und habe
mir gedacht wo sie aufpassen dass sie
nirgends anstehe
weil vom motorrad nicht weg kommen aber
immer im zelt geschlafen haben die
ganzen sechs wochen
dadurch waren ziemlich aufgeregt am
motorrad und dann bin ich wirklich noch
im letzten moment mit 23 km
73 dahin geschlittert und mit 23 km h
bin ich genau davon stehe und der
leitschiene auf dieser kannte genau an
gestanden und dort hat man denen den
einen wir eben den l1 zersplittert und
ja durch rückenmark gedrückt
witzigerweise ich habe wie gesagt komme
aus dem motorsport aber bekannte die
ähnliches passiert ist ja davor und der
robert jonas das war mal sechs meter
groß bereitet mir erzählt dass er im
ersten moment das gefühl gehabt hat wenn
seine beine brennen würden und ihr
wirklicher halbe sekunde später das
gefühl gehabt obwohl sui runter schaut
mit bewegen ist nicht gewusst wie
scheiße schauen wir mal was rauskommt
mir war bewusst
im ersten moment ist es schwer zu sagen
ob sie jetzt als ob es wirklich
rückenmarksverletzung ist darüber zum
beispiel ist wieder zusammen gekommen
das hat wirklich wieder zu 99 prozent
die funktionen zurück bekommen na ja
genau und die mine voll aber es hat eben
so dass noch drei monate dann absehbar
war dass nicht mehr alles druck kommen
wird und eben den kompletten querschnitt
teil 1 zu circa nabenhöhe führen der sie
von den fachbegriffen auskennt das jetzt
gesagt dass relativ schnell verstanden
hast was da jetzt potenziell auf dich
zukommen wird wie es dir da in der
ersten phase gegangen nachdem dir das so
schnell auch bewusst war haben wir die
erste aquabella interessante geschichte
ist mein ball nicht ist nicht ganz so
gut
und sonst kommst dort nichts gesprochen
aber im dritten krankenhaus war ja auch
einverstanden das ist ein apparat ist
und ob dann aber wirklich glück im
unglück gehabt war in der nähe von
warschau die polnische spezialklinik für
rückenmarksverletzungen und die obere
ärzte waren erst seit zweieinhalb jahren
aus amerika zurück mehr oder weniger
sind dort eben die operationstechniken
und so gelernt
dadurch haben natürlich auch fließend
englisch gesprochen und ja ich habe das
gut erklärt was sie machen würden was
sie empfehlen würden mit der verletzung
und vernünftig gelungen
dann habe ich meinen hut liegt runter
haut wie es so schön heißt
und wirklich auch die operative
versorgung hat super funktioniert ohne
irgendein zwischenfall war und wir
wollen und bin dann mit dem plan steht
nach österreich zurück wo es das mentale
betrifft muss sie die meisten zuhörer
sehr immer enttäuschen will
vielleicht bin ich zu viel sonnenkind
oder wollen wir auch immer bedanken muss
ich habe wirklich nie dieses große
mentale tief gehabt erstens hobbys im
sport vorher schon gelernt mit
verletzungen umzugehen und zweitens ist
ist für das wirklich die wichtigste
phase oder die wichtigste was sport im
allgemeinen bei bringt das einfach egal
was passiert im nachhinein kannst nur
mehr als beste draus machen und jetzt
wirklich in der situation ganz gleich
sehen ob es jetzt sagt kreuzband reißt
oder etc hat vor ihm einige verletzungen
gehabt den motorsport und es bringt
nichts und ob es jetzt selbst dran
schuld ist oder wer anders dran schuld
ist es bringt ja genauso nix sagen du
hast immer zwar
entscheidungsmöglichkeiten im leben wie
mein blick dorthin richten wo sie
verloren haben sie neben account oder
will ich meinen blick dorthin richten wo
sie eben noch beeinflussen kann und was
ich machen kann im leben und das hast du
dann auch gemacht und das hat auch sehr
rasch auch sehr gut funktioniert der
fall war sport warum bist du nicht im
motorsport geblieben sondern beim
triathlon sport machen aber wirklich so
möglich weil motorradsport war dann
einfach so war damals perfekt ich hab
morgen noch der reha genau antrag zu
hause aber zeiten dort wieder bei ktm
gearbeitet in der entwicklung habe die
möglichkeit gehabt das haben natürlich
die wenigsten wieder so in den gleichen
job zurück zu gehen und dadurch eben von
klein auf immer sehr sehr einer
energiegeladenen mensch habe ich einfach
wieder was braucht ja wo immer
energielos wert und deswegen hat zwar
nur dann auch schon mal erst das
handbike kauft würde es irgendwo im
daher schon einmal probiert habe und
dann klingelt lässige aus mordes könnte
die machen auch und jozo ist einfach
gewachsen werden
ich bin die ersten halbjahr hinweg
wurden und dann haben wir gesehen
triathlon ist auch für rollstuhlsportler
möglich macht eigentlich klein und geile
sache vorher schon aber bekannte
konzentriert lang gemacht haben und
dieser begriff hawaii weil ich im
hinterkopf das werk coole
herausforderung zu versuchen
erstens triathlon zu machen nun schauen
wo spielt mir ihnen sollen in der ersten
phase ist wirklich eher um das erleben
gegangen und das wo eigentlich gar nicht
so geplant dass die profikarriere wird
aber wie es heute ist im leben ist
einfach von jahr zu jahr gewachsen und
gewachsen und die haupt begannen von
meinen wöchentlichen arbeitszeiten über
fünf stunden runter zu streichen und 1
gb haben mitgespielt genauer bin
wirklich ein wachsender markt ist ist
wirklich zu meiner zweiten sport liebe
worden
und jetzt mache ich schon seit 2011
wirklich profimäßig und zeit vergeht
ganz einfach und auch sehr erfolgreich
ich habe da stehen 2010 2011 2015
weltmeister in aromen bewerben im
paradis hat lohn und para triathlon und
ganz wilder rennen wie das race across
america auch mit dem handbike schon
absolviert also wirklich in die langen
distanzen gegangen oder wenn man jetzt
den triathlonsport der schwimmen
radfahren laufen erkennt wie würdest du
es beschreiben oder wie würdest du den
sport für rollstuhlfahrer jemandem
erklären der zum allerersten mal von
pará triathlon für rollstuhlfahrer hat
also im prinzip sind die die drei
gleichen disziplinen wenn man auch
schwimmer dem hinschaut ist es wirklich
total das gleiche die komplette kraul
bewegung ich habe ihm nur bei den füßen
der fixierung einfach erschienen die die
füße zusammen hält weil er einfach nicht
spüre war meine füße sind und beim atmen
könnten sda überkreuzen und dann kann es
mir irgendwann vielleicht auch den
rücken drehen aber das ist der einzige
unterschied sonst ist die gleiche
bewegung und man startet auch meistens
mit neun bewerben ist kommt dem verein
barra triathlon sind oder ganz normale
offene triathlons im großen feld
also gibt es nicht wirklich ein
riesenunterschied
ihm wird auch sofort die langdistanz
betrifft ist auch dann noch weil nicht
so
extrem gross will einfach so ist beim
langdistanz schimmern kommen maximal 10
15 prozent von den füßen und der rest
kommt von den armen und dadurch ja
deswegen so stimmig nichts was lange der
situation und die rollstuhlfahrer ist
einfach so je kürzer die distanzen
schwieriger auch nur annähernd
mitzuhalten
deswegen ist er für mich als rollstuhl
athlet bin ja sehr gut dabei gewiss als
beispiel wenn jetzt in klagenfurt 2500
statt da sind dann kommen wir als
250.000 dem bereich aus dem wasser
heraus gegen den ich bin nicht behindert
genau wann sind ja trainingsblock immer
es sonst wirklich jetzt ganz normale
schwimmtraining und ganz normale
schwimmbewegungen der radsport ist bei
uns eben der handbike sport dies ist von
den komponenten her also bremsen
schaltung laufräder auch als ganz
gleiche wie in der fahrradindustrie nur
natürlich das sportgerät an sich ist
wirklich komplett an den körper
angepasst dass man liegt wirklich
komplett flach am rücken
und ja die kurse bewegen uns die kraft
kommt wirklich nur aus dem
schultergürtel vor allem bizeps
belastungen schultergürtel das heißt man
kann sich das als als liegerad mit
handkurbel vor ihm haben für die die uns
nur hören genau am besten erklärt
liegerad mit handkurbel und von dem werk
sagt von den komponenten her schalten
ganz gleich wenn der fahrradindustrie
und auch was die trainingssteuerung
betrifft also vor allem auch alles mit
leistungs messer er hat dynamik versucht
man sich verbessern also wirklich die
ganz gleichen gesetze wie im radsport
nur durch sport ihre dass ein gewisser
spezielles was auch vor allem
individuell an den eigenen körper
angepasst ist und die dritte disziplin
ausblieb ist eben das laufen dann
vielleicht einige von euch gesehen haben
dieses rennrollstuhl fahren ist im
weitesten sinne wie ein alltags
rollstuhl aber natürlich wirklich ein
sportgerät also ist an hinten 2 28 zoll
räder leicht schräg gestellt und vorne
ein kleines 20 zoll rad aber eben im
gegensatz zum handbike waren zum
radsport gibt es doch keine schaltung
sondern ist es nur durch diese kontakt
reibung
also man hat einen handschuh war
gummierter handschuh ist und bei dem
drei reifen ist auch ist auch gummiert
und nur durch diese kontakt reibung
damit wird der vortrieb werden erzeugt
durch die schlagbewegung auf die drei
greifen und vom sportlichen ja ich
vielleicht so zu erklären natürlich mit
dem handbike mit dem oberarm muskulatur
ist man nicht so extrem stark wie er via
fahrradfahrer und dadurch verliert man
dort etwas zeit ist etwas langsamer
dabei muss man auch sehr gut dabei ist
übrigens beim letzten ironman 39 km h
schnitt 280 kilometer wir sind so
langsam aber dafür ist es soweit es beim
beim laufen habe natürlich mit den
rollstühlen vorteil
und was ganz wichtig ist dass die
absolute weltspitze jetzt im
nichtbehinderten triathlon und dem bad
laer sie auf ganz ganz ähnlichen zeiten
trifft wenn man eben dafür 15 jahre
training investiert und das ist bei dir
ganz schnell ich habe hier stehen das
september 2017 einen neuen weltrekord im
paradies war sieben stunden 48 minuten
über 3,8 kilometer schwimmen 180
kilometer radfahren und eben die 42
kilometer rennrollstuhl fahren also
wahnsinns zeiten wie du sagst das ist in
der nähe von den absoluten top zeiten
der nichtbehinderten aber jetzt das
spannend parra triathlon dass das jetzt
erklärt und auch ins detail
man merkt eine passion dafür und
parodiert und ist er seit 2016
paralympics das heißt im programm
gewesen bei den paralympics und rio und
du hattest wahrscheinlich viele jahre
vorsprung auf alle anderen athleten in
diesem sport und der bisher in rio
trotzdem im handbike angetreten dort
auch sie über gemacht
ich erinnere mich dass das wir uns alle
sehr gefreut haben wie du die medaille
gemacht hast aber warum dann im handbike
und nicht im triathlon er ist wo
eigentlich so dass sie mir jetzt vom 23
10 wecker bisserl neue reihe von 12 dann
schon bilden neue herausforderung
gesucht habe und die herausforderung war
einfach im handbike ihn um einiges
größer und beiden qualifikations
kriterien wollte die mit stern weil
barra triathlon hat nur über die sprint
distanz ausgetragen wird
totaler wettkampf leider nur eine stunde
und die qualifikationswettkämpfe wären
wirklich rund um die welt gewesen mit
australien japan und denken das baby zu
viel also mal so sportbegeistert das
mittel der reise aufwand wäre zu groß
gewesen vom leben neben dem händchen er
seine parkinson
also wäre zu groß gewesen beides zu
versuchen und dafür immer dann haben
gesagt okay dann entscheide mich für
eine ist und da wollen wir die
herausforderung im paracycling die
größere und ja deswegen ist wirklich die
entscheidung dorthin gefallen die
wirkung zwar würde auch jetzt noch gerne
gerne starten bei dem wms und größeren
rennen im paradies wird leider nicht
erlaubt weil er eben die
qualifikationsrennen nicht bestreiten
wird
sie sagen war bislang clinch mit der eu
mittlerweile findet das ohne mich statt
tor kein leistungsmäßig hobbys mit einer
weltkarte an jahr wieder mal bewiesen
dass sie wahrscheinlich nach wie vor
nach derzeit stärkste der welt bin
aber man kann man auf jeder hochzeit
sein und auch die anderen auch zeit
reiche funktioniert bei dir ja super
erfolgreich und du bist eben nicht nur
ein top-athlet sondern auch schauspieler
in dem sie nun möchte ich nicht sagen
oder hat es schon einen film der über
die hier gedreht wurde warst
hauptprotagonistin dann im eigenen film
one man show die zwei seiten der
medaille
worum ging es dahin in dieser doku über
dich und warum sollte sich das unbedingt
wieder anschauen
es war eigentlich so also eigentlich auf
freier filmemacher privat eigentlich so
nicht hauptberuflich der schon
es war ja für mich herangetreten und ob
ich etwas machen möchte
ich habe dann darf man da bitte kein
mensch braucht er weitere sportler burg
oder was auch immer
und haben eigentlich ziemlich der wert
dagegen und irgendwann erster halb zwei
jahre später wir nun endlich seine filme
angesehen die er gemacht habe ist
dorthin und anna waren hat das glück der
anderen
da geht es darum wie menschen glück für
sich definieren und das andere hat die
rolle meines lebens da geht es darum
wenn es im dem sinne männer zum ersten
mal vater werden
und darauf habe kapiert ok man kann auch
das anders machen nicht nur reißerisch
und nicht nur im sinne von wie super
dass man ist und ja warum ist es
gestattet werden und wir wollten einfach
ein filmporträt machen über ca
dreiviertel stunde unter halbjahr
getroffen und hat mehrfach wettkampf
begleitet und da geht es einfach darum
ja warum es macht im kürzesten gesagt
warum ist einfach mache was mir dazu
antreibt und ja was im hintergrund
abläuft und wie es dann witzigerweise
ist sehr sehr gut ankommen ist im kino
laufen in einigen kinos in ausgewählten
und später auch im orf und kann man den
film noch irgendwas nicht die wartezeit
auf 16
aber wenn jetzt jemand hier zu hören ist
ich glaube ich unbedingt also youtube
eingeben und dann findet man das jetzt
auch gesagt er soll erklären warum du
alles machst ich habe ein zitat von dir
das haben ist langweilig die
herausforderung ist wichtig wie darf man
das verstehen dass möchtest oder mit
musik jahr stellung ist nicht einfach
ein hat messner nicht wegnehmen
von reinhard veser und er wird immer zu
erklären mein sportlerherz schlägt im er
im takt eines reinhold messners oder
eines roald amundsen anstatt eines
klassischen moderne olympioniken sagen
also mir geht es wirklich darum mich
selbst zu beweisen oder über mir mir
selbst ja zu prüfen
fragt sagen so und das finde ich sehr
weise aussage einfach es ist glaube ich
wie ich dich ja dass man versucht sie
ständig selbst zu hinterfragen im leben
und vor allem auch im sport und das ist
nur wenig befriedigung bringt sie auf
irgendwas erreichtes oder erlebtes
auszuruhen zu versuchen und ich glaube
es wichtig zu versuchen sich ständig
selbst zu hinterfragen
und wenn du eben dann die antwort kommt
dass man sich wiedersehen nach neuen
herausforderungen
dann ist es auch wichtig die zu folgen
vor allem im sport ja ich sage ich
glaube es sei wichtiger ein wichtiges
attribut für sportler dass man nicht
jeden und allen folgen darf also ein
bisschen dagegen strom schwimmer ist
glaube ich ganz gute fähigkeiten für
sport war dass das kannst du jetzt
natürlich besser als die meisten
beckenschwimmer wahrscheinlich aber wenn
du jetzt sagst dass dich das ein
bisschen auch ja klassifiziert das dass
du jetzt erzählt hast würdest du dann
auch ein bestimmtes ereignis aus einer
sportlerkarriere herausheben können wo
du sagst genau das symbolisiert das was
ich zeigen möchte ob jetzt ein erfolg
oder ein prozess also jetzt muss mich
persönlich betrifft ist es schon so dass
sie nach wie vor was meine persönliche
sportliche bewertung und wertigkeit ist
es beim bei den armen ein und glaubt es
das beste rennen oder die zwei besten
rennen bis jetzt gemacht haben bei dem
2017 in podersdorf und heuer im august
in deutschland neue leipzig beim knappen
das an was die sportliche persönliche
befriedigung betrifft wie die sorgen
sagen dass die zwei dinge die wirklich
perfekt gelaufen sein
aber ich bin wirklich dankbar für so
viele unglaubliche sachen die erleben
dürfen ich habe irgendwo zwischen 320
und 350 rennen mittlerweile machte auf
jedem kontinent und über reue und die
waren so viel unglaublich schöne
erlebnisse dabei auch negative aber die
sind im endeffekt ja auch schöne
erfahrungen
aber das kann einfach alles zu der reise
dazu und wie hält man das wirklich nicht
vorstellen können und ina bauernbub aus
südost
ich bin wirklich mit sehr wenig
selbstvertrauen
wie soll ich würde sagen erzogen worden
oder groß worden ist war er etwas was er
an negativen touch hat wenn man
selbstvertrauen hat aber immer versucht
seinen ideen zu folgen als würde hätte
mir das nie erträumt dass sie irgendwo
die erlebnisse einfach erleben darf
einfach gezogen dafür ist das wirklich
ein riesenschatz worüber ich sehr
dankbar bin
könntest du zwei drei dinge auch
herausnehmen dinge die du gelernt hast
die du dir dass sport auch nach dem
unfall bei gebracht hat wo du sagst das
ist das ist dass die erkenntnis die ich
aus dem sport gezogen habe für mich als
thomas frühwirth der sommer so das hat
nicht unbedingt mit dem unfall zu tun es
war eigentlich so dass sie mit mit 18
bin eben wirklich meiner leidenschaft
und es war ihm damals schon das
motorradfahren gefolgt bin schon mit
sechs jahren mit neuen jahr backwaren
und so war schon immer wieder motorsport
auf ihn
die freiheiten die ein bauernhof mit
sich bringt und die hat mit zehn ja
wirklich schon gewusst
ich würde es sehr sehr gern
leistungsmäßig motocrosser ventura
vornehmen haben die möglichkeiten gehabt
würde mein vater hat dabei umfeld wenig
interesse daran gehabt hat mit es zu
finanzieren oder zu ermöglichen und zu
der zeit und dann auch später mvm
simulation von sie 12 13 14 15 16 17
hobby auch die entwicklung mit kopf und
wollen das selbstvertrauen nicht ob das
system trotzdem vielleicht versuchen
würde und ob das auf vox nick macht ist
man unsere jugendlichen so beibringen
laufen und ich habe versucht es relativ
erfolgreich zu machen und als größte
sportlichen erfolg wird wirklich
betiteln chemie ist es dass sie mich von
diesen muss dann getrennt habe das ist
mein größter erfolg dass sie verstanden
haben mit 18 das ist selbst dafür
verantwortlich bin für mein leben und
dass sie wenn ich etwas erreichen will
selbst die aktionen setzen muss und und
sonst wie eben dorthin kommen wo ich
vielleicht hin will und das hat ja den
kopf in den sand zu stecken diese ganz
egal mit welchen schleiern die man vor
seinen kopf zieht welche drogen oder was
auch immer das ist halt immer der
einfachste weg aber der bringt anbieter
net hin und das was ich ja der größte
erfolg bin dann eben wirklich zur ktm
und entwicklung raus bin dort gleich
genommen worden
und ob verstanden sie selbst
verantwortlich bin und das heute sicher
sonst mit der leidenschaft damals zu zum
motorradfahren oder maximal im triathlon
so nicht gebraucht sondern so nämlich
überhaupt in ein umfeld groß werden
mit sport nur kann man nur zu dürfen und
bis jetzt noch die gedanken vertreter
sport bis zum 8 ich glaube du beweist
dass das eben nicht und genau das
gegenteil der fall ist
man merkt dass das du sehr
herausforderung getrieben bis jetzt hast
du schon alles gewonnen was man gewinnen
kann in deinen jeweiligen sportarten
was sind die nächsten herausforderungen
wenn es in richtung tokio geht bis jetzt
seit drei jahren beim heraus sport auch
als herzsportler dabei kannst dich
dementsprechend auch als profi
vorbereiten was was reizt dich noch was
aber es treibt mich noch an
für die nächsten jahre sportlich gesehen
sportlich gesehen ist es ganz einfach
gesagt dass es natürlich die paralympics
sind in unseren in unseren sport oder im
behindertensport die größte nummer und
die verpflichtung gebe ich gerne ein mg
darzustellen dafür wird dort ja
natürlich ich hoffe das nächste jahr
stattfindet wieder dass das große ziel
sein
und nach wie vor seine scheuklappen
natürlich hätte auch vorstellen dass
vielleicht dann noch weiter geht ja es
kann auch zur zum sport man muss sie
natürlich ist nicht nur später zu seinen
sonetten nur ja auch sich zu bewegen
oder sport zu machen oder die tätigkeit
zu tun sondern man muss auch versuchen
sie dementsprechend aufzustellen und
zwar das kann sich auch finanzieren zu
können und dadurch ist natürlich gehört
die paralympics ein riesenthema
da hat sie in den letzten zehn jahren in
österreich um sehr sehr viel geändert
sehr sehr viel zungen zum absolut
positiven hin
und so wie es jetzt ausführen könnte es
mal ohne eben den herzsport der
sporthilfe sanft eben neben dem polizei
sport und und der finanz sport die
wichtigsten säulen im österreichischen
sport solchen spitzensport könnte ebenso
nicht finanzieren also das ist einfach
mit mit privaten sponsoren wenn es aus
einem umfeld wie ich kann es ist es
wirklich relativ schwierig ganz einfach
gesagt in wirklichkeit läuft 80 prozent
über vitamin b ab und vitamin b haben
nicht viel und dadurch aber durch sein
ja
man muss natürlich auch sie dem stellen
wo die finanziellen möglichkeiten
beherrschen und das natürlich auch den
paralympics dadurch ja nächstes jahr und
und dann schauen wir weiter und suchen
sonst einfach die uci
weltmeisterschaften und und der weltcup
sowie jedes jahr im prinzip es nach
macht man nach wie vor noch wahnsinnig
wahnsinnig spaß ich hoffentlich bis sie
sie sorgen andere lebensweg oder
lebensziele bin nicht unbedingt der
klassische familienmensch es muss jeder
so handhaben wie als möchte sagen wir es
so und solange meine meine überzeugungen
aber wie vorhergesagt
selbst hinterfragen und meine antwort
liegt noch dort möchte das gerne
weitermachen dann geht es so lange
machen wie man das einfach spaß macht
und wie leistungsfähig bin und wenn ihr
leid nicht mehr leistungsfähig ist
komplett mehr leistungsfähig bin dann
kann es mir nicht mehr finanzieren
du hast jetzt eben auch die die bahn
wächst als großes ziel weiterhin
natürlich deklariert aber werden die ich
die paralympics auch als triathlet
einmal erleben schätze sei die chance
groß ein oder solange nur die
kurzdistanzen an olympisch sind sind da
die chancen eher niedrig ich habe
eigentlich wahrscheinlich wenn ich damit
abgeschlossen
wir haben wahrscheinlich nicht sehen
sagt sag niemals nie im leben gesagt man
sie dann fünf jahre später wieder
revidiert hat was auch immer der firma
zurzeit ist wirklich was die
qualifikations kriterien der eu betrifft
ja habe ich glaube ich noch ziemlich
intensiv gemeldet dagegen mittlerweile
deutlich mehr wagen qualifikationsrennen
wir einen startplatz bei seite ist
einfach so sie haben also dass das nicht
behinderten system eins zu eins im
paradis eltern übernommen
mit dem unterschied dass ihre
nichtbehinderten system 60 starter
erlaubt sein und im beirat der nacht
statt der erlaubten
und jetzt haben werden teilweise
sinnlosen rennen punkte ausgeschüttet es
ist wirklich ein hieß es aus sportlicher
sicht krank und unfair und durch das bei
mir meistens auf granit
also wenn ik weltcup bekomme fia
weltmeisterschaft aber oder wir eine
europameisterschaft weil wir natürlich
schwere gelernten ja man merkt auch dass
das du dir da auch kein blatt vor dem
mund nimmt und auch deine meinung sagst
du würdest du jetzt zum abschluss auch
sagen dass dich das auch charakterisiert
dass du auch wenn dir was einmal am
herzen liegt dass du das auch so nach
außen kommuniziert ja mach ich sicher
ist natürlich ein zweischneidiges
schwert muss er ganz offen sorgen ich
kann auch ein schwieriger typ zeigen ist
so wie es immer ist das eigentlich kein
sagen sie was ich jetzt keine jobs jetzt
positiv oder negativ ist finde ich
genauso situationsabhängig und wie
vorher schon erwähnt ich glaube dass
sportler muss man bisher eigenbrötler
unter viel eigensinn lassen vor allem
wenn man dann lange distanzen und unser
ähnliche geschichten machen würde
er ist auf jeden fall authentisch echt
und erfolgreich es passt für mich und
andere will ich nicht bewerten und das
milliman herausnehmen
danke auf jeden fall für deine einblicke
alles gute auch noch für die vielen
sportlichen herausforderungen und
natürlich auch für alles was noch so
kommt wir freuen uns wenn wir dich auf
diesem weg begleiten dürfen
danke dass du hier was beim sport
reporter tom sehr gerne danke danke
danke dass es auch hier wieder beim
sport rabatt dabei war es heute
thomas frühwirth als gast der spannende
persönlichkeit ich freue mich wenn ja
auch nächstes mal wieder einschaltet bis
dann und auf wiedersehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]